[Music]
uh
hey you know we're going to stop global
warming bill gates has this great idea
you're going to love it oh this is mr
burns block out the sun plan
who made billions out of creating super
clunky corporate software
what you didn't realize is that bill
gates doesn't think of himself that way
bill gates doesn't think of himself as
some guy who got super rich making bad
software
look he's really the head software he's
really [ __ ] on windows [ __ ] and
honestly as a windows user i agree
tucker is such a [ __ ] [ __ ] clunky
is [ __ ] i always say this about tucker
but i i could i could see myself
leaping over a table at him he's just
that much of a [ __ ]
smug brick for some guy who got super
rich making bad software
bill gates thinks of himself as god in
control of the solar system and that's
why bill gates is now backing something
called
sun dimming technology finally
finally i mean i don't mind so much here
in florida but
yeah you guys oh thank you you guys are
gonna be falling if you're somewhere
where it's cold
negative 90 in minnesota in march
they would reflect sunlight out of the
earth's atmosphere
causing global cooling oh
that's not fraught with risks you
thought gain of function
research on pathogens was dangerous try
that but that doesn't stop harvard
university
its scientists are testing that
technology by spewing calcium carbonate
dust wait wait they're already testing
this of course no no no
i've heard of this thing before but it
was always a joke they're actually
actively testing it now
uh yeah how do you expect them to get it
done
chemtrails aren't at least even mr
burns's plan wasn't this bad because it
was just like this
metal thing that literally blocked the
sun like a one city
this is the planet by spewing calcium
carbonate
dust into the atmosphere bill gates is
backing the first high-altitude
experiment of one
radical climate change solution creating
a massive chemical cloud that could cool
the earth
this is the buccal cloud sorry this is
the beginning
of an apocalyptic movie am i the only
one that finds
the term chemical cloud a little bit
concerning
you know what i got to tell you right
now people that believe in chemtrails
are like
see you [ __ ] see so we're gonna
coat the planet in chemical clouds in a
chemical cloud
yes okay so
all right then that's also the name of
my chemical romance fan group i'm a
president of
creating a massive chemical cloud that
could cool the earth
it's called solar geoengineering and
it's highly controversial
it would look something like this
thousands of planes would fly very high
and use nozzles to inject
gray trails of what we could maybe
say uh are chemicals
like some sort of for short i would say
like let's call them chemtrails
so your planes would spray these
concentrated chemicals
into the air aerosolizing them uh
and and pumping chemicals into the uh
into the air and the solar system
am i getting this writer was alex jones
right again
oh no no and by the way i hate chemtrail
people and i hate the fact that they're
right
but they're literally showing you
a chem trail from an airplane
thousands of planes would fly very high
and use nozzles to inject millions of
tons of light reflecting particles into
the stratosphere
there's no long-term effects for that
can we i don't know
can we do a test run on another planet
first please i love that this is again
being pushed by the people who
supposedly care about the environment
i care about the environment so much
that i need to put uh
metallic chemical compounds into the air
that block the sun
that's how much i love the earth
create a thin chemical cloud of those
particles around the whole planet
blocking some sunlight from reaching the
surface it would mimic a giant volcanic
eruption which
is that a good thing i mean ask the
people of pompeii if that was a great
thing yes
technically it's worse because it's the
whole planet
well because a volcano eruption and the
resulting ash
is natural it's part of the earth's
process
right so you're just spewing uh
chunks of earth and dust up into the air
and it temporarily blocks out the sun
and eventually that stuff works its way
out of the stratosphere
this is worse because we're spraying and
i quote
a chemical cloud into the atmosphere
giant volcanic eruption which we know
cools the earth
now just to restate bill gates is not
god
bill gates is some kind of weird
socially awkward rich guy who lives in
seattle he doesn't own the planet
oh pretty [ __ ] close dude
but he's now changing the planet
single-handedly this is not just over
his yard in seattle this is over your
yard
and our oceans and the whole planet now
according to forbes
frank kutch who's the project's top
investigator quote
does not know what the results might
bring
i'll just experiment with the globe and
find out what happens it's cool though
he's a billionaire
michael schellenberger is the author of
apocalypse never
why environmental alarmism hurts us all
which it does
as our rivers and oceans get dirtier and
no one notices uh michael it's great to
see you
tonight thanks for having me it's a
little alarming to think that
someone as myopic and out of touch and
totally ideological
and weird as bill gates a lot of
adjectives tucker
and also he's a [ __ ] yeah he keeps
slipping in weird yeah
several times weird weirdo [ __ ] nerd
he thinks he's in charge of the planet
but like if bill gates
grew up in the 90s instead of the 70s
right he would have been a school
yeah there would have been no
opportunities and people like him are
usually the ones that are like i'll show
them something but listen to him talk
show these [ __ ] shocks
yeah now that's the guy we're letting
spray i want to reiterate this race a
chemical cloud into our stratosphere
i just want you to know that that's what
they that's their words by the way
i don't i don't want to get hit by
youtube for misinformation
i'm using their they're going to use
planes to spray
chemtrails of chemical clouds into our
atmosphere
to block out the sun i
can't make it i'm not it sounds like a
super villain's plan
it's literally mr burns it's the mr
burns plant he's becoming mr burns
this is something you say when you're
high with your cousin you know you're
like
bro what if we like block the sun out
that'll stop global warming
and now he's helping fund it in a
harvard
what if what if like the powers that be
oh [ __ ] i've always made this joke that
like what if what if the deep state and
the powers that be really actually are
good guys
and they're really just trying to push
everybody over the edge so they finally
fight for their freedom
and like what if these guys like all
these guys are like meeting these
intelligence guys and these billionaires
in these darkened rooms smoking cigars
and they're going
look nothing's working right we
literally just told these lazy [ __ ]
that we're going to blot out the sun
with chemicals
and they're still not doing anything
like we have changed the social
experiment yeah
i really i really just just have this
theory that
the deep state are really the good guys
and they're like we've been poking them
to try to
get them to go over the edge and finally
take back their cut and they're just
they're really lazy man like we've moved
up now to
operation sunblock and they're still
just like i guess that's okay
like we're gonna force vaccinate them
we're force vaccinating them
and they're not allowed to leave their
homes without a special id card
but we're also letting illegals vote
without id
and somehow these people still aren't
killing us i just don't think we can
actually push these people and motivate
them his next plan is going to be to
just nuke the fault line in nevada like
lex luthor did
for beachfront property look half the
[ __ ] we've been saying on the news is
just to [ __ ] with these people
but it's like they don't listen no
reaction
i go hey guys check it out uh you're not
allowed to have a job anymore
cruise lines are shut down and you're
gonna have to have a special id
to travel and we're forcing a vaccine
we're gonna have army trucks parked in
front of your house giving vaccinations
and we're also blocking out the sun with
chemicals
and these people just i don't know maybe
they're
but like they just keep looking at me
like okay
yeah it's fine it's fine why don't you
block blot out windows updates every
five minutes bill gates why don't you do
that instead
you think they're just poking us with a
stick going come on
do something clippy pops up and says it
looks like you need help plotting out
the sun
yeah it's yeah so anyway that's what
we're going to use
planes to spray chemicals that will
block out the sun
are you listening huh yeah i don't know
do you want to go i'm hungry whatever
man
nobody cares what should we hey guys
look
he's gonna block out the sun with
chemicals see nobody
can somebody do that put bill gates on
that meme that would actually be great
i mean basically everything i mean when
i first heard about this
many over two decades ago this was a
thought experiment
but this is real they're really trying
to do this they've they've encountered
opposition every step of the way yeah
because you're trying to blot out the
sun
i've co-authored by the way because now
there's a bunch of people going uh yeah
we knew chemtrails all along
all you [ __ ] doubters look i never
doubted that they didn't experiment with
the atmosphere and spray all kinds of
[ __ ] into it i never denied that
the problem was that a lot of you would
take [ __ ]
videotapes of these regular like boeing
767s and go
look look look like there are still
contrails too
and a lot of uploaded thousands of
videos to youtube going
here it is huh day 11. and this is plane
number 24. look look at the back look
look at that and you're going well yeah
because it's really high up and it's
he's writing jesus loves in this guy
it's a sky writer
but i never denied like look at monsanto
in this [ __ ] yes
people have been spraying cancer into us
for [ __ ] 40 years now
articles with the with the harvard
investigator we've told him personally
this is a terrible idea
the vast majority of scientists disagree
with us you have to remember what
they're proposing to do
is identical to what we feared would
occur after nuclear war in the 1980s
which is nuclear winter
the idea is that you cool the planet
deliberately the effects on crops are
completely unknown
yeah but he owns like the majority of
farmland in the u.s you can look that up
that's actually true bill gates does
they call this an experiment but they
know that there is no way to figure out
what the large scale
planetary effects of this kind of thing
would be it's gross so you're telling me
that i'm not allowed to have a plastic
straw in california
but bill gates can blot out the sun
as a thought as an experiment also can
you explain to me
why i'm looking at the real-life news
and the banner underneath says that i
just want to quote this again
please please dimming the sun could
backfire in dangerous ways
why am i living in a robocop movie it
does
this looks like one of those robocop
vignettes in between the scenes that's
what i mean it feels like just
you're like why am i in a paul verhoeven
film
right now this is like john carpenter's
[ __ ]
just looking at the wait like if i woke
up one day and i was just like
oh man i'm like trying to get some
coffee going and i'm not really awake
yet like
turn the tv on and that's what i see and
it's like
i would just be like wait am i awake
are we turning off the sun should i call
my local congressman
this has to be a joke is this a joke
is it true you guys are turning off the
sun i'd like to know what time
then it's dude it's crazy because i do
remember this from many years ago they
were just you know talking about it but
everyone was like oh that's crazy
they're doing the experiments right now
mostly irresponsible they know for a
fact that they will never get
international agreement on this
so they're basically trying to socialize
the idea normalize the idea
make us comfortable with an idea where's
that
tactic come from i've never seen that
done before
i have but i can't say it because i want
to stay on youtube
yeah that should make us extremely
uncomfortable
yeah a guy who cuts his hair with garden
shears is now trying to control the soil
oh talk oh tucker
the funny thing is anyone who notices
this that maybe bill gates has
outsized control over our lives is
immediately denounced by
snopes or these fraudulent fact-checking
sites it's like conspiracy nut
do you think you're a conspiracy nut to
have concerns about bill gates's hubris
and ambitions
no i mean this is uh this is bonkers i i
mean
honestly there are an underrated disney
cartoon from the 90s
very few people when you talk to them
privately i think it's a good idea
there's a lot of people that are very
scared to speak out publicly because
bill gates's influence is extraordinary
he's a massive philanthropist i think
his intentions are very good
nobody doubts he's well intentioned but
good i do
i doubt that he's well intentioned
intentions can lead to some very bad
things the amount of hubris
and arrogance involved here we're
talking about millions of farmers around
the world who will be affected by this
how will they be consulted what is the
idea for how this is going to be
governed
there is no plan for governance there is
no way to get agreement on this
internationally
they know this you know tucker the thing
is the trends on climate change most
people don't realize they're going in
the right direction
the united states has reduced its carbon
emissions what about china
what about the india right what about
china
or india going up it's going up
[Music]
have you ever seen videos of like like
there's some like beaches in like
vietnam and indonesia that are like
literally just it's all plastic waste
like you can barely see the water
and it's like partially those countries
that are doing it but a lot of it's just
washing over from india and
like there are i've seen videos of
beaches where
it's it's a sea of plastic just
like rushing onto the beach and you're
like wow dude
by you know more than any other country
over the last 20 years
we've had an extraordinary success in
the united states in reducing our air
pollution
and now we're now we're faced with the
prospects of this radical experiment
if there's one thing we can do to
improve our country overnight it's tax
tax-exempt non-profits people like bill
gates make billions
they die but they continue to distort
our society with these tax-exempt
foundations we should tax them
immediately pay the rate we pay today
that's not good that's not gonna happen
tucker tucker's joker posting but
i doubt that's gonna happen bud highly
doubt it